easter bunny came here
and look what the easter bunny did
the kardashian jenner clan put together
a lavish easter celebration for their
family over the weekend members of the
famous family took to instagram to share
some pics and videos from the
festivities which took place at family
matriarch kris jenner's home the fun
included giant chocolate eggs with each
family member's name on them look at
this table look at these baskets for all
of the grown-ups
as well as easter baskets behind each
attendee's table setting and a table
filled with tasty treats from cupcakes
to cookies to carrots and actual eggs
the queen of everything
kylie jenner kim kardashian khloe
kardashian and courtney all gave praise
to their mom chris for hosting the
family and when it comes to the next
generation of kardashians kylie shared a
video of stormy getting creative as she
painted her easter egg
and this video was shared of north who
unlike stormy wasn't interested in
showing off her masterpiece
chloe captured true with her easter
basket overflowing during the easter egg
hunt
true did you find another one
true what'd you find
are those all your eggs
and she snapped this adorable shot of
true and rob kardashian's daughter dream
standing side by side smiling from ear
to ear
look at this
in addition to the weeknd's fun and
games kylie gifted chicago true dream
and stormy their very own gumball
machines in pink purple and baby blue
and that wasn't the only treat she
dished out for the holiday the makeup
mogul also shared the first glimpse of
her baby boy whose official name is not
yet known on her instagram story in the
quick pick travis scott the father of
kylie's children is seen holding the
two-month-old close as his tiny black
and red sneaker rests against the
rapper's waist kylie
baby number two
et spoke with the kardashian jenners
ahead of the premiere of their new hulu
series the kardashians
and kylie opened up about where she is
when it comes to naming her and travis's
new bundle of joy congratulations
but not a wolf why not wolf
and
what is the name wolf was never on our
list
um
it just was actually something
chloe suggested and i like don't do this
i liked the name i don't think anything
i still like
i love it i love it i like wolf
i just wasn't him so do we have a name
no okay we have we have some um
we have some
really strong options but we haven't
officially changed we have some
placeholders so before i officially
change it i just want to be sure you're
seeing that little personality oh
congratulations thank you